Ladies and gentlemen,
one of the best boxers on planet earth
and his trainer BOMAC and Terrence
Crawford. Gentlemen, thank
you very much for coming here.
Thank you ma'am with live now.
Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Hey man,
I'm a big fan of yours. I've, we've
talked about many times on this podcast.
I'm a, I'm a huge fan of the way
you switch stances. You know,
you switch switch stances as
smooth as anybody ever. Like,
like you got to go back to Marvin hag
or to find a champ that switch stances
like as fluidly as you, it's
pretty, pretty impressive stuff man.
Have you always been doing that?
A lot of practice. Yeah,
since I was little.
I remember getting in trouble
cause I used to always switch him.
My coach just thought he'd say you need
to worry about fighting that one style
first and perfecting that before you
try to try to switch and do it different
style. But I'll always switch. So it got
to the point where there was just like,
all right, well you're
going to fight like that.
We're going to train it like that.
Wow. So you've forced it
through. Right. Wow. Now,
when you first started out,
was there anybody that influenced
you to switch like that?
Or was it just something
you felt naturally
or was it just naturally wow.
It was just like, all right,
this is not working so I
gotta do something else.
Just make it more tricky.
Right. Yeah. Well that's,
that's part of what's interesting
about watching you fights,
watching you fight is that you could see
you trying to figure out what's up like
first rounds with when you fight is one
of my favorite things to watch cause I
see you measuring dudes,
I see things happening and you switch
and stances and then when you start
finding the timing,
it's like timing is one of the more
fascinating things to watch about boxing
because a guy who has
perfect timing and perfect,
like when you see a guy make a read
and then execute and it's perfect.
It's one of the most beautiful
things in all of sports.
Right? Right. It's like you, you know,
you watching every move and then
you just dissecting them slowly.
How do you think, do you
think about it? Like when you,
when you start around a
first round of a fight,
is it different for every fighter
or do you always want to do that?
Do you always want to like put them
into the computer now is different.
It's different.
Like sometimes I just want to go out
there and just be like, all right,
I'm going to see what this dude,
God, see if he can tell you,
just go right to them. Yeah.
And then sometimes I just be like art
and I'm gonna take my time and you know,
figure him out, see how
fast he is seeing, you know,
what things he liked to do on what he
don't like to do or see if I moved this
way. His reaction, just certain things.
It's a, you know, we, you came
to the UFC this weekend and uh,
and obviously I love MMA,
but one of the things that I love
about boxing is when you take them all,
all the elements you take away wrestling
and kicking and all that stuff,
you get the highest level of
an exchange of your punches.
And you get to see with guys like you
guys like Canelo or Floyd or the the top
level boxes you get to see what's possible
with guys that are training with the
best scientific methods and with all
the knowledge of all the past fighters.
I mean, when you were growing up, who,
what was the fighter that
influenced you the most? Well,
hands down, Floyd Mayweather
and Roy Jones jr you know,
I used to love watching Roy Jones
jr I'm pretty sure everybody,
everybody was a fan of Roy, but set aside,
Roy always watched it. Floyd
Mayweather and Pernell Whitaker. Yeah,
I was too young for sugar
Ray Leonard and them.
So I'm old enough for that. I was
there for the sugar Ray Leonard days.
I was there for sugar Ray, Tommy Hearns,
the, the, the sh, the sugar Ray Duran.
I was there for all that stuff. But
I w I watched everything when I was,
when I was young, my coach, ms miner,
he used to always take me to his
house and watch boxing tapes.
That was the keep me off off the streets
and keep me out of trouble until I went
to the gym. Is he still around now?
He passed. Damn. He probably like,
look at that. What did
that work out? You know,
we talked about an investment in time
that the worked out tremendously. Yeah,
the, the, it's always a,
in our culture there's a special
place for the highest level of boxers.
It was like a special
place of, uh, admiration.
And I just feel like with guys like Loma
Chanko with guys like you with Canelo
and tripleG , this is a great time
for boxing. It's fun to watch, man.
There's so many. Earl Spence, junior,
there's so many elite boxers right now.
It's like a really exciting
time. For sure. For sure.
Do you recognize your place in history?
Do you recognize that? Like you're,
you're a special dude?
Of course. Of course.
Like I always tell people when they,
uh, met your me and Errol Spence,
you know, of course I want the fight.
I'll tell everybody I already
say with or without him,
I'm going to the hall of fame.
When you look at audit things that out
of and co accomplish in the sport of
boxing people that's in the hall of
fame, then you've accomplished that.
You know? So I was, I just tell people
I don't need him. He really need me.
Well, we need it blocks. Right. Don't you
agree you're boxing? Do you need that?
Boxing needs it. I mean,
it's one of the beautiful,
beautiful things about when a Canelo and
a triple G do get together and you see
these guys and their respected way
classes that are in their prime. It's fun.
You know? Like that's what everybody
wants to see. That's the fight.
That's what it's all about.
It just stop a whole lot of Barbara
barbershop conversations. Yes.
We need to stop a whole lot
of comedy club conversations.
Barbara chop garage
everywhere. Yeah. That's the,
that's the fight to make in your weight
class right now, right? For sure.
What's hole? What's the hold
up. You gotta acts down. Oh,
it's that we, everybody has to
hold out a little bit, right.
To get the best deal. That's great.
That's cool. You know, uh, it's,
it's all about business,
but at the same time, uh,
my side of of the deal is ready whenever
and you can see all the interviews out
there. Man.
You could see where if it's tears
from myself or Bob or anybody that's
affiliated with team Crawford,
we all say wants to fight,
you know? Yeah, we had a fight tomorrow,
you know, if we wanted to, so, well,
we know it's leery,
Alyse, it won't happen.
Right.
So when w what do you think that he's
waiting for the right time marketing wise?
Or do you think he's
ready for the right time?
Where his skills he feels like
are able to challenge you?
Like what do you think
is the actual holdup?
I think is, has something
to do with top rank and PBC.
Oh, okay. So it's a promoter issue.
So it's a financial scramble.
I won't say financial because the money
will be there if the fight was ever
made. I just think it is,
you know, Eagles. Yeah.
I think he goes up the price of Eagle.
Do you think?
Hopefully this is just something
that's going to take a little while,
but it will eventually come to play.
Of course, I think, uh, it
happened, you know, but I think,
you know,
me being with top rank and standing in
the way of a lot of things happening.
Mmm, that makes sense. That
makes sense. He's like,
it's interesting that promoters or boxing
promoters worked together well at all.
Right. You know,
like you think about it like if the
UFC had to work with Bella Tor and put
together some world
championship fight every,
basically there's so many times
we get champion versus champion.
They have two different promoters and
they have to decide to get together and
make this happen. Who want to
get the more, most of the pot.
That's probably what it is. Yes,
it's going on Fox or ESPN and
who's going to promote it. And
it's also like when someone like Floyd
Mayweather has done what he's done and
sold the kind of paper views
that he's sold and then you know,
and achieved this sort of level of
financial fame as well as like people,
he's famous not just for being the best
boxer but famous for being insanely
rich. Like that's part of the fame.
Cause he promoted yes cause he promoted,
cause he figured it out and a lot of
other people are gonna probably try to do
the same thing as well. Right. That's
that's not my style. Too busy. Right.
Too busy. Yeah man mean you got to
just stay busy being Terence Crawford.
Do you want to be promoting that? Seems
like a lot of a pain in the ass. Well
just [inaudible] I do want to
promote it. I run my mouth and fit.
What about after you're done? When your
career is over, when you've retired,
do you think you'd do some promoting
then or training? What did you do? Nah,
I'd just be uh,
in my gym back at home and my coach got
us a gym and just put my time and effort
into the kids in the gym and my
five kids that I have. Beautiful.
Yeah, that's a, that's a,
that's a solid plan. You know,
you don't need to get involved
in that promoting shit.
Now it do get to the gym sometimes and
working with the fighters, do you? Yeah,
I got that funny because it's funny to
see work with them because after about
two rounds he came to this shit man
cause they're not listening like you
telling them over and over and do one
little simple thing and like just say
you tell them to keep your right hand
right. And they keep going like this.
Like are you talking about brand new
people like yeah, like even even boxers,
dad's being boxing for years that they
really don't have the fundamentals down
to a tee and you're like, dude,
you been boxing too long for you to
still be making the same mistake.
And it's like, I only can
say certain things for solid,
for certain learn for S for
solid learning. And then
it's just like, alright,
I ain't saying it no more. Well, yeah,
your opinion is as
valuable as anybody alive.
Do you one of the best
fucking boxers ever.
If you're a beginning boxer and Terrance
Crawford teaching you something,
you're not listening. You're
probably nervous as shit.
[inaudible] for sure. But that's crazy
that you'd be working with beginners.
That's, I must be wild for them.
They must work with all of them.
That's awesome. That's kind
of freaked them out though.
Especially the ones that's professional.
And they'd be in the gym
and I'd be yelling at them.
They'd be on a mess with BOMAC.
I'll come over there and critique them
and they'd be like, shit, here come bud.
They look at me like, am I doing it
right? Am I doing it right? And you know,
so I just want everybody to win.
I'll just keep them sharp. Well,
when someone has achieved that level,
the level that you have, you know,
like anybody around you that gets
a chance to watch your train.
And be a part of that. That's, that's
gigantic to see something like that.
And in the gym when you agree
just to see like a world champion,
I mean for just having
him around, you know,
in the gym when he's not even posed to
be training or just being around in the
other fires around is phenomenal because
you'll see this little extra pussy and
the guys sure.
You know or like he'll come and run
with them and I can see the smaller guys
just want to try to get ahead of him,
you know? So it's cool man. It's cool.
It's really cool. Yeah. That's
a do you think about that?
That how much you inspiring
guys? Of course. All the time.
That's why I come to the gym when
Bomag be like, man just take a rest.
Just relax. I come to
the gym and workout when,
you know I don't have nothing
coming up just so I can show them.
Like even though I'm the
champion of the world,
I still work extra hard to make sure I
stay champion cause it's harder to keep
the championship title then getting there.
It's one of the more beautiful things
about boxing is there's no shortcuts.
None for the best ever. You have to
train, you have to train hard as fuck.
You just got to do well. You don't want
to do it. There's no doubt about it.
You got to do everything you're supposed
to do. There's no if, ands, or buts.
And if you don't fuck with your head,
and that's one thing I
took from Floyd Mayweather.
You will always see them working out.
I don't care if he was at a bar,
you'll see him running from the bar.
He got his little workout
clothes and his little TMT, uh,
van and he just ran home. Like, I'll
use him three o'clock in the morning,
man, let's go work out. You know?
And that's what I admire the most of is
his work at his work ethic is off the
chart. Does the only way you be that
good? There's no other way. I mean, yeah,
he understands boxing at a level
that, I mean, grew up with it.
Having his dad and his uncle and all that.
The family was so many great boxers
around him all the time. But he,
you don't get that good without insane
work ethic. There's no shortcuts.
No, not at all. I,
I have never seen nobody like
put as much work in as Floyd.
So that's why, you know, for
me, I'm like thinking to myself,
I gotta work twice as harder, you know,
if I want to get above him because
I never want to be like anybody.
I always want to be myself,
but I want to surpass the people
that I was in front of me.
Was it, um, eyeopening when
you got to watch him train?
Of course. Of course. You know,
when I was younger it lets me know
that I wasn't working as hard.
Yeah. So now when,
when fighters come to my camp or I
bring in some sparring partners or some
friends that's professional
that just want to, you know,
come to camp and just experience, just
being in camp with a world champion,
they all say the same thing, man.
I thought I was working hard till
I came up here, man. You work man,
you work too hard. And, and
the thing for some people,
cause some people they just be
like, I can't do it today. Like nah,
I'm gonna let y'all do them too.
I'm going to go to the gym but I
ain't gonna do the other stuff.
And I just be like, man, come
on man. They'd be like, man,
my body and be like man, see that's
what it's going to determine.
Winning and losing. You complaining
about your body when you can rest later,
you know? Right.
What other stuff you're
trying to get them to do?
I know you do a lot of stair running,
right? I do a lot of everything.
I do yoga and I do street
relation. I do swimming,
hot yoga to do hot yoga. I love that.
I joke I used to do it two times.
I believe that everybody can do it.
It's just a mixture of, you know,
just all around body working out. What
do you find that you get out of yoga?
Oh man. Yoga is harder than you
think. You know, you in there,
you got to control your
breathing. You know,
just holding your hands in
certain positions is tiring.
So the little muscles that you
really not using, you know,
in a day to day activities you use in
a yoga and it's just burning and you're
just like, man, just hold your hands
up like this and going like this.
You be like, you be in
there shaking like man,
it's kind of burning and you see the
girls and you like trying to do it and it
just, it helps you with
your balance as well.
Yeah, it helps me with a bunch of
things. It's just interesting that uh,
more fighters don't adopt it. You know,
I think anything that makes your body
more flexible and increases your range of
motion and then gives you strength and
all the, it feels like when I do yoga,
like all the connecting stuff like
the shoulders and hips and knees,
all that gets like this extra stability
workout that you don't get from a lot of
other things. I feel like it connects
everything together. Good. And it,
and it helps you prevent
injuries. Yeah. Yeah. No.
So now w speaking of that, like what do
you do in terms of recovery? Do you do,
uh, ice baths or sauna and
massage, that kind of shit.
Massage and um, I don't, I don't
like the cold so I need to like,
I don't really take absence. All
bass. Yeah. Just did massages.
That's a grownup in Nebraska thing
though, right? What's that cold?
It's cold in Nebraska,
but I'm used to that cold but I just
can't fix myself to get in the ice tub.
[inaudible] I never was that
type. It's hard. It is hard.
I'd be like, you pick your
poison. I stick my feet in there.
It'd be like I ain't getting in there.
Yeah, it's rough. They'd be like,
come on, it's going to help you. All
right. It's gonna help me next time cause
fuck. Have you ever fucked
with cryotherapy? Ever
tried? I did that one time.
That's easier. Yeah, it was cool.
Cause only triads. Yeah. Dry, dry.
And it's only three minutes. So,
but that, that ice bath, yeah,
I'll do the car crier. Ice bath.
Nah, you want it. I'll be sore.
I don't know what the science says.
What's better? I've heard both things.
I've heard that the ice bath better
cause it's prolonged cause it's like 15
minutes and I've heard the cry was better
because you hit your body with such a
high degree of cold that freaks out
and produces these cold shock proteins
better. Either one. You do those,
um, you do massage. Do you do yoga?
What kinda S I know you do
strength and conditioning stuff.
Gotta watch your Instagram, you've
got a great Instagram. Right.
And your kids are wrestlers,
right? Yeah. That's awesome. Yeah.
Do you think your kids ever fight
MMA? Nah, I actually, I'm on,
I'm trying to convert them to baseball,
really piety in the next year,
you know, because it ain't, it ain't
that much money in wrestling. It's true.
You know, when you look
at the MMA fighters, uh,
they ain't making a lot of money to
get beat up. Like they getting beat up,
like look at, uh, pedis.
He broke his feet. Right.
You know, but yeah, it looked like he
broke one of his ankles maybe. And,
or at least heard it. I'm pretty sure he
didn't make over 300,000 for that shot,
that fight. I'd like to know,
see if they find out how much the
Anthony Pettis made for that fight.
He broke his foot for sure. Yes. Oh yeah.
He was walking around or being pushed
around in a wheelchair today on Instagram.
Yeah. It's rough. You see people
getting need kicked in the face, teeth.
Do you look at it as being more
brutal than boxing? Yeah. Yeah.
You're taking,
you take more risks and UFC it's like
saying more head injuries but UFC more
risks for yes, for sure.
For injuries, right.
Broken bones and ankles
and knees and shit. Yeah.
And I just didn't get and where fall that
boxing ain't worth a lot of things too
cause you seeing people
die in the ring and uh,
and they ain't worth your life at the
end of the day when you decide to hang it
up. How will you know when you never,
well me personally, I won't
think I'll ever know when,
but I just got to date and the
age and like, alright, you know,
middle thirties. How old are
you now? I'll be 32 next month.
So your close, close. So you have
it in your head. Just got on top.
Like Marvin Hagler was one of the only
ones that ever do it. He went on top,
another switch hitter.
Marvin Hagler was the only one out of
all the greats who lost that fight.
Controversial loss to sugar. Ray
Leonard is like fuck this, I'm done.
He walked away. Nope.
Never ever came back.
[inaudible] his last fight was a
religion. Yup. Yup. That was it.
Controversial laws to let her
became a movie star in Italy.
He ever seen his movies in Italy? No.
I just watch some clips. Hilarious.
Marvin Hagler fucking people
up. He's like, Oh a movie star.
He does like these crazy
Italian movies. What is this?
How much he made for
155,000. Wow. 55 if he won.
But so Dee has made a flat
two 50 for the win. Yeah.
The, they used to before the Reebok deal,
they used to make much more way
more for sponsors. Yeah. Cause, uh,
I've got a buddy Marsala baked it.
You know that guy? He's really good.
Very talented. Brassica. Oh is
he? Oh, okay. Cool. He's fun.
Brought Bosnia buddy lives in
Lincoln, Nebraska. Okay. You know, uh,
real, real good friends. Real good
friends and talented kid. Yeah.
And they just always say art,
well we get paid for this.
If we win this for showing up this,
if we get best knockout out
of other data, this is more,
this is why we to Hagler as this
is why money is an action hero.
And this is like not far after
the fight with Indio too.
Cause there was a lot of lot of shit
that was unresolved after NGO one.
He was a, I've never seen that. Oh this,
these are the spaghetti
westerns like, but for you know,
whatever year this league
Harvard Haggard shoot,
everybody can speak the
language. Uh, yeah. Yeah.
Apparently speaks little Italian and
you know, he's a star over there. Wow.
Yeah. Look at, let me see.
But he just decided like, I don't want
to [inaudible] box anymore. I'm done.
That's good for him
though. Yeah. You know,
I mean to get punched in the
head no more. He speaks perfect.
When you hear him speak today, they do
a, you know [inaudible] never, never.
I'd love to, yeah, I'd like
to meet that guy. I was,
he was my hero when I was kid. Yeah,
I remember there was a video of him,
he was trained for Mustapha Hampshire
and he's running down Cape Cod in the
winter with a, with a hoodie
on, just screaming war. Whoa.
All the cold coming out of his mouth,
that steam and he's running. I was like,
Oh my God. Cause I was, you know,
doing martial arts back then and I
was watching him call him like that.
That's the ultimate champion.
That's a chamber that puts
himself in a terrible play.
Puts himself down on the Cape in the
winter time to do all his training in the
cold runs in the cold and it does
it in runs and combat boots too.
He ran in combat boots
and he would just be,
he was hard as fuck and he just had
crazy work ethic, crazy work ethic.
And I remember whenever I would think
about being, thinking about being lazy,
I would think of him running
down the beach going, Whoa,
just to just shadow
punching in the beach. Oh,
it's crazy that you say that because
I remember when we was little,
we used to always run in the cold. I mean,
it would be so cold where the snow
is freezing up. You tearing up,
but as you get older you'd be like,
man, I ain't buy run. And I go down.
I ran on the treadmill. You already know.
You already know. You know how to fight.
You know you know how to persevere.
You already know you're a champion.
You already know you're
at the top of the game.
You don't have to prove
that to yourself anymore.
You know how tough you
all know. No times that.
It'd be times that I'd just
be like, all right, we,
we need that hardcore work.
Let's go every name. I be like,
what? We ain't going
to, why not? One time.
One time we ran right
after Thanksgiving, dude.
Oh no. Right after,
right after Thanksgiving.
I don't get out there. Just get and
get in the truck. Let's go. Cool.
So he may, he made Thanksgiving
dinner and we in training camp,
so you know we all gotta lose weight and
stuff and Paul made all this fool man,
we all grub in this stuff and then so
I'm eating, after I get down eating,
I'm like man, I'm stuffed. I'm like man,
I can't wake up this heavy. I was like,
man everybody let's get
it ready to go around.
And everybody looking at me
laying down like, man, it's cold.
You treat you for it. So we run
it with these little flashlights,
like the little yellow man like
[inaudible] you go fishing and stuff.
So we all run in air by hunting
dude, dude, dude, why that night?
It was, it was pretty chill. Wow. Yeah.
But that kind of shit like
what Floyd may wear that does,
that's that two o'clock in the
morning workout routine every night.
Like it's good to just throw
monkey wrenches into your
sense of what you should
be doing and when be ready to do it.
Always. Yeah. That's why they're cold.
Weather running is big.
Cold weather running is those people that
live in cold climates that run in the
winter. Man, that's us.
That's a hearty breed.
A human that's not a regular person that
decides like nobody's got a gun to your
head. It's not your job.
You decide to put your fucking running
shoes on and lace up and go out there and
when it's zero,
it's kinda like when before I fought
America and I was down there shadowboxing
and in the snow and I blizzard. Oh yeah.
I w I'll it on, I'll put it on on
my Instagram. Everybody was like,
Oh he traded for Spence like 10 10 inches,
10 inches that day and it was a pleasure.
And we actually got knocked off
a couple of days of leaving.
Leaving for training camp. Yeah. Wow.
Cause there was so much fucking Snowden,
but there's something about that, like
even you talking about it, you know,
it's kind of wild.
You're out there boxing in the snow
shadowboxing in the middle of a blizzard.
Something wild about that.
It's crazy though because when it's
snowing it's not that cold. Right.
It's true, isn't it? Yeah. Like
insulates a little bit in some weird way.
I was just sitting in the house
and it was just like, man,
go outside and do something. So I went
outside, ran a little bit and dinner.
I come home and I was like, come here.
He's like, what? Like come and record me
shadowboxing and stuff after I
ran. So it was cool. So when,
when I see you doing those, a little stair
runs, you do that quite a bit, right?
Right. Every Sunday.
What did he do that in a around probably
won't tell anybody where you go.
They know they know last spring. Oh
okay. That's, that's a famous spot,
right man to to experience how many
steps is that? That whole thing.
Something crazy. Right? This is, it's a
mile and a half up. I know it's a Mount.
A mile up a Hill. How long does
it take you to get up there?
Probably like 35 minutes before fucking
horrible run and I run and walk.
We walk up but some people running.
Oh you walk it? Yeah. That's insane.
Then people that'd be running the same
cause the air been thinner and thinner as
you go. And then the steps, you got
some steps that's like this, that small.
And then you got some steps where
you got to really reach. Oh like,
so if you're running the slip,
yeah, it's a fucked up crumble
for real. Yeah. Like when you,
when you were up at the top,
I feel like you were in
the clouds sometimes like
looking down like the cars is,
it's a straight shot. Would you
do your training camp up there?
Colorado Springs, right? Just for
the altitude? Yup. Yeah. Actually uh,
got a house up there. Oh really? You
just go back and do that for each camp?
What made you decide to do camps out
there? Just to get away from home,
you know, clear my head, get
away from all the negativity.
And I've been doing this since 2013,
37, 13, 2013 so, so do you have a
gym set up at, at the house. Oh,
that's nice. I saw like Canelo had
something like that down in San Diego.
There was a thing when he was
training for one of his fights,
they just rented the house, turned the
garage into a boxing ring. [inaudible]
that kind of thing. You
have all set up out there.
A lot of guys do that at big bear too,
right? Yep. It's similar today. Okay.
Yeah. Having that high altitude,
is that what you prefer?
Like look for for your wind?
Yeah, that, that helped my win,
but at the same time everything
is, is already set up.
Like everything from the yoga to the
swimming to the gym to everything.
It's like a second home to me. So it's
not like I got to go look in the fine.
Where am I to do this?
Where I'm going to do this?
It's like everything is
everything and you know,
my family come up there and
visit me and we get the job done.
That's all locked in right
now. When you go up there,
who sets your schedule as far
as what your daily routine is?
I know you said everything, yoga,
all, everything. Well, it's, it's uh,
it's two more coaches that that helps
me. Solid Diego's and red spike.
So we all get together,
we make a make a uh,
calendar like a month in advance.
And now when you do things like
when you add in yoga and swimming,
how do you know when to put those
in? W w everything was always,
it started off with a trial and error
back in 2013 grab that microphone pulled
up close to it. There we go.
Like I said, it's around,
it moves all over the place,
right? Every, like I said,
it's done with a child
or an ear. 2013 you know,
we tried this and we tried that and then
we started doing this and we started
doing that. And then, you know, just,
you just look at the fighter and just
see if it is, if it's working for him,
you know, and if it's working for
him, you want to stick with it.
And then you start adding little small
things into it. Like the old gun,
the swim in the run and
you know, the incline.
And so after so many amount of
years, I think we've been since 13.
I mean he just worked like clockwork now.
Now do you monitor in your heart
rate or how do you know, like do, do,
do any of that stuff while you're
training? Nothing. Just go by feel. Yeah.
Yeah. There's uh, two
schools of thought, right?
The schools of thought is like
the old way is the best way.
Like just do hard shit. Chop
wood, you know, run, do the,
do the standard stuff.
And there's other people that watch
their macros and you know, they're ma
smiling. You're not watching, I know
what you're talking about. But I don't,
we don't do none of that. Yeah.
I think we trained more or
less like the old school way,
but we do got like some of the new
stuff in like the strip, the condition.
We've got district to
condition a guy Jamie belt,
he's excellent and he kind
of adds a little stuff,
new modern age stuff in,
in, uh, into the workouts.
Like sometimes I'll be wanting to
do more and he be like, nah, I was,
I was enough for you. Like, you might
not think you did enough, but trust me,
you'll feel it tomorrow.
What? You wake up tomorrow,
you like God really is
sore. If there some ties,
like I'll add some stuff and just out,
you know, try and make things different.
You look at me saying now,
but we're not doing that.
[inaudible] already be like Danny.
He's like trying to add extra stuff
or would be like one more round.
All right,
come on one more round and then you'll
do that one more round and they'd be
like, all right, we got one more round
y'all. You'd be like, man, you'd be like,
man,
I just pushed everything down to that
last round because you said that was the
last round. Well come on baby. Come
on. I'm not about to argue with you.
So you can be great. So like,
all right, well the fighter,
it's like there's this,
this gotta be a balancing point, right?
Like you don't want them to do too much.
Right?
So like when that guy told you like
that's enough for today and you're like,
want to keep going? That's the natural
inclination is to work harder. Yeah.
It's that weird balancing point. We gotta
figure out when you're over-training,
right? It's if you're not monitoring
your heart rate or anything like that,
you just basically have, you have a
flat day, you feel flat, just chill out.
Yup. Yeah, sometimes. Yeah. Sometimes.
Boy always asked me before we go work
out, how you feeling? How you feeling?
Like I'm good at ball, I'm good. Or
sometimes I'd be like, man, I'm tired.
Like he'd be like, all right,
well we just gone coast today.
Like if a Spartan day
he'd be like, all right,
well don't be trying to do too much. We
just gonna spar, hit the mist, get out.
We ain't gonna do no bad. We
ain't gonna do nothing next year.
And then after I do the bagging,
sparring, I mean not the bag,
but the missing spar. I might be
feeling good and I'd be like, man,
let's do action and be like, nah. You
say you weren't feeling good at first.
Listen, come on, let's go. That's
the hardest part right there.
Pull up to know when to pull it back.
Right? Because he, he knows me. He
been with me since the beginning,
so he knows just by looking at me,
you know what type of day I'm having,
like either in the gym or outside the gym.
That's gotta be important, isn't it?
Like knowing him from the time when he
was younger and just start now to today
is definitely his way.
Plays a big part in the relationship
as far as like say inside the ring and
outside touring. Cause uh,
you know, as a trainer, you,
you'll never want your fighter to
overtrain or you'll never want him to
under-trained. So, but w I,
I'll never have to worry about him under
training because he's always in the
gym,
but I do have to worry about him over
training because he always in the gym,
you know what I'm saying? Yeah. Like
you said, some days and be like, man,
maybe we're gonna pull back
this week. Why, man, man,
you've been training for already
for eight weeks, you know, so,
and we still got one or two more weeks
to go before we hit the down date,
the actual peak point, you
know? All right. What level
we have, we'll pull back,
you know, and then sometimes you yell
at hardheaded and say, no, come on man,
let me do a little bit more.
Alright dude. A little bit more,
but don't do too much. You know, you ain't
gotta put your all into it. You know,
just, just, just move around
a little bit. You know,
you got to do basically all fighters
like that. He says she fighters,
good fighters.
Cause most good fighters like
Terence and other fighters.
Jamelle herring, Steve Nelson, you
gotta you gotta pull them guys back.
You always gotta pull them back cause
they always want to go, go, go, go, go,
go. Cause I always got this winning
gotta fucking win. I gotta fucking win.
I understand that. I want
you to fucking win too,
but I want you to break your body down.
I don't want you to [inaudible]
you're boxing inside the gym.
You got to have something
left when you go to the fight.
That's a lesson that's very hard for
young guys to learn around. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Yeah. But it's so critical to know
where you body is. And at
this stage of your career,
I would imagine you just kinda
feel it, you know? Exactly.
And when you're in training camp
and you're gearing up for fight,
is that how it feels like you
know where you're at? Like, Oh,
this is where I'm supposed to be. I feel
this right here. Oh, he's just normal.
It's funny though, because every fight,
every single fight before the fight,
you know BOMAC always [inaudible]
waiting to hear me be like,
Aw man, I'm ready. I'm ready.
Like sometimes it'd be
a week before the fight, sometimes
it'd be two weeks before the fight.
But when he hear it, that's what I'm,
that's what I been waiting on.
It's like, nah, nah, I'm not,
I'm comfortable because like sometimes
he, he just be like, he'll look at me,
I'll be working and stuff and
then he don't say nothing.
But then when I come to him like,
yeah, I'm ready. He be lightened.
He said he ready. You get
that from the fighting,
right? Fuck down. Shit man. We'll
beat this motherfucker Zack. Well,
because you guys know each other so
well and you worked together so long.
Like you must like say, okay, here we
are, we're where we're supposed to be.
Right. You've, you've been there,
falls right into place. All right. My,
my biggest thing
in that,
I always told bone every since I was
an amateur because I remember losing a
couple of fights because I didn't train
as hard and I got tired, you know,
and I couldn't really do too much
and always told bill. I said Bo,
if I'm in the best of my shit,
best shape that I possibly can be in
nobody being nobody named Baldwin,
I know
that's why you need to
quit bullshitting. So,
so it just got to the point,
real friend that's a real
trainer and a real friend is.
So it just got to the point where I just
start like training real, real hard.
And I was just like training not
to go over you in this happened.
I was a teenager. I'll just
start training, not to get tired.
If I can go in there and fight
and not get tired, I'm a win.
That's what I always stayed
at. So the switch flipped. Yup.
He figured it out cause I was losing
the people that I shouldn't have lost to
just head down just swinging wall. Wow.
But they was in shape and I was trying
to be all cute and slick and get tired.
Now it's a matter of life and death,
knee hole. And they pushing me.
I'm falling all over the place
as a, as a little kid, you know.
And I was just like, I'll never get
that tired ever again in the fight.
Dad is such an important lesson for young
fighters to hear such important lesson
that it's, there's no shortcut. When you
look at a guy like Terrence Crawford,
you'd say, well that guy
must be insanely talented.
I mean his timing is reads on people, the
ability to switch dances. And he said,
well duh. Yeah. Well
how'd that come about?
That talent came about through
relentless hard work. Right? That's what,
that's what makes that talent
emerge. I'm sure you have a,
an amazing inclination for boxing.
Every elite of the elite fighter does,
but you don't get to be there without
any hard work. It doesn't exist.
There's no way. There's no,
it's so important for young fighters
to hear and that's what a lot,
a lot of guys that don't see you
as that hard work in the jail.
You know what I'm saying?
[inaudible] with anything that when you
look at any top fighter and you look at
all the sacrifices they make
just to be where they at and you,
you have people taking shots at them
and stuff and they'd be like, man,
yo know what?
I didn't put my body due to be here today
or you didn't know what I went to went
through and is just like total disrespect
for somebody that haven't even stepped
foot in the ring to be trying
to critique you when they ain't.
They ain't even stepped foot to
get punched in the face before.
They can never really
understand though, right?
No one could ever really understand what
it takes to be an elite boxer when your
whole, the future of your
family, the future of yourself,
your financial success and all the
people around you is dependent on you
navigating the most shark filled
waters in professional sports budget,
train killers with their hands.
Everybody's real good at knocking other
people out with their hands and you are
successfully navigating
those waters like Nope.
No one really understands
that other than you, right,
you and all the other people like you
will like the real me people on the
outside that are close to you
kind of get it a little bit.
You are the only one that's ever
going to be able to understand that.
So all those people talking shit like
they might as well be speaking a language,
they don't even know what the
meaning is. Fact, it's nonsense.
Just say nonsense and it's just like
you got a bullseye on your head in your
back because you, you, you reverse first.
You had your eye on somebody
and you was like, man,
I gotta beat this door after this
dude. I gotta beat this dude.
So you was I in that person that
was in your shoes, you know,
that was once champion of the world.
Like I was iron Ricky burns when I was
coming up, you know, and not there.
I be him now. Everybody's
IME because I'm chatting now.
So it's no more Ricky burns.
It's Terrence Crawford.
We got to get Terrence Crawford. He's
the chin. So now, and it's like damn,
everybody wants your head.
So now you've got Cheney were harder to
keep the title [inaudible] got show up
at your gym. Talk shit like Shannon
Briggs style and nobody coming home.
The hall man, Shannon Briggs
where his weight class,
he would show up in Omaha. Let's go
try to break. He's a Lyria. He will leave
on the hall the same way he gave me.
He told me I got beat up by somebody. Uh,
do you ever see what he did to Vladimir
Klitschko when they cut each other and
then when they were,
well there's a couple of times one at
a restaurant poured water on his head,
but he comes out that's right
from the broken glass. Right.
But the other time was, Oh, he was,
he was on a wakeboard or
on a paddleboard and uh,
Shannon came by in a boat and knocked
him off the fucking bat and the waves
fell. That's, I picked that
one stage, all that stuff.
I think it was seems like it was
stayed just like, man, how are you?
You know where it is, man. That every
single time he lets go some point.
It's good point and then you just so
happen to have some good cameras getting
the footage. It's true.
Then wasn't good cameras,
but Shannon wisely would travel with
good cameras and then just start making
these these scenes. He never fought
him. Yeah. He didn't ever fight them.
Yeah. I think you fought him when he was
younger or something knocked him out or
something like that. Vitaly Vitale
knocked him out. Yeah, he fought.
He fought the older brother
Vitaly. He was a monster. Yeah.
That's why we fought. Right. I
believe Vito V it's how you say it.
That's how you say vitally does. That
guy had an iron jaw. The brother.
Nobody could knock out
the brother. It was crazy.
That guy would just take bombs.
Remember when he fought Lennox
Lewis immediately? Yeah. Took bombs.
I mean that that guy
was so God damn durable.
He would've won that fight if he wouldn't
have got that cut. Giant cut. Yeah,
he was winning. What a
weird style too. Right?
He had the one of the most awkward, like
so strange watching him throw punches,
but it was effective and he remind
me of a Drago off Iraqi a little bit.
That guy's a doc, like he's got a pH D
I think he speaks like five languages.
What'd they call them? Doctor iron
fist was that his name was a character.
It's interesting too,
like the heavyweight division has now
become the focal point of boxing again.
It's very exciting. I was
like, yeah. For a long time,
Vladimir Klitschko was the heavyweight
champion of the world and for whatever
reason, nobody gave a fuck.
It was weird because he was
dominating all those years.
He was jabbing clutch, jabbing clutch,
because we didn't have the American
champion for sure. So everybody was like,
Aw, forget it. We went there.
Probably something to do with it,
but if he was fighting, it's like,
can you just find the way
dr Deontay Wilder does?
Who cares if he's from the moon? Right.
You start showing people like that,
like we want to see that guy fight. Like,
you don't care if that guy's from
fucking Brazil, wherever he's from.
When you're laying there right
hand, good night, God damn.
It's one of those punches
where people just go,
you see people in the audience
go, God, he hits hard.
Even when he don't fully extend.
It'd be like the crazy thing is when he
fought Tyson fury who was two Oh nine
two Oh nine, just nothing to
any punches. So fucking hard.
It's crazy. That dude is a, an anomaly.
The fact that he won a bronze medal in
the Olympics three years after taking up
boxing. Right. Does insane.
Insane. It's just insane. Yeah.
Cause there a lot of people they asked
me, cause we was in the same, you know,
trials in 2007 and it was like,
do you ever remember Deontay Wilder
and, and the amateurs? I said, man,
he came out of nowhere cracking people.
He never went on none of the,
the uh, duals or nothing.
He just came out of nowhere. Yeah.
He's all the top guys
in the division. Crazy.
That's a, let's say he's a unicorn.
You know when you look at his record,
what is it like 39 knockouts out
of 41 fights, something like that.
40 knockouts, 40 knockouts and
41 fights all his four year gate,
39 39 years. Two only two fights. One.
What is it a the first one was
it Brazil dump? No. No, Brazil.
He just knocked out. Who was, who
else who went the distance? Stubborn.
Stubborn went the distance and their
first fights. The Vern and yeah,
and then he flatlined him in the
second fight. That crazy one.
Just the hits dude. Why
in man, people go flying.
He got the law. He got
the right last name. Wow.
What's he doing? Wow, he's
start. How about that?
To this day the dude interviewing
was like, shit, what did I do?
What the fuck did I do? And then
he uses hashtag till this day.
He uses that all the time when his
Instagram so that guys gets shellshocked.
He gets PTSD every time. Rash
hashtag till this day. He's like, no,
I, it's funny though, because we
all, we all be saying that now
till this day. I am going back
to that. That story told him,
yeah, he took that phrase over.
Yeah, that was a, that was a phrase,
you know that he just owned. He took
it over. That's his now. All right.
That's it. That's this one
interview till his day.
One interview, one interview before
a fight. He's getting geared up.
But you seem to look
all my God. Terrifying.
Terrifying.
When you know how hard that guy hits
and he's mad at you like this muffler to
knock me out for sure. 100%
he would never do that.
It's like you beat your in the room and
a lion like, Oh no. And he's aggressive.
He's mr lion. Oh, you
sure this thing's trained?
You sure it's not going to
eat me. He's so, he's there
too. That must have been terrifying.
Please blink fully geared up and ready
for me for war before this fight.
That is [inaudible]. That is
hilarious. That is hilarious.
So this whole division. Now, if you look
at the heavyweight division between,
you know, Andy Ruiz just
beats Anthony Joshua,
and then they're going to try to figure
out what they were going to try and do
that in Saudi Arabia. But apparently
Andy's like, while I'm fighting America,
he should took gay guys in Saudi Arabia,
a big money fight. I'm sure. Well,
they're still gonna do it.
They just arguing over where
is it off the table now?
I don't know this. I did. Who knows, man.
I mean, you guys know better than me.
It's a lot of games have been shipped by
like where you're talking about before,
ego and stuff. Same kind of deal, I'm
sure as the arrows. Spence jr fight.
Same kind of deal.
They're jocking to see who could get
the Andes worried about I'm taking from
[inaudible]. Yeah. He's worried about
taking some Mexican supplements. Right.
While he's over in another country that
they won't test him. So he should have
Vata or yes. Right. Testing that is
going to go over there and you know,
testify it. Yeah, that's a,
that's one of the reasons why people
gonna love a dude like Andy Ruiz as a
champion. Like he, he looks like a
regular folk. Right. You know, he's like,
he's got a lot of extra body fat.
He's a bad motherfucker. But you know,
Anthony, Joshua looks like
he was made in the lab.
Just got a perfect physique man.
It's crazy how, how big dude guy?
He's huge cause man he wasn't that big
at first, but now he's slim it down.
But I think he put on a
lot of weight to, you know,
carry with vitamin mere
Klitschko please go.
Is that when you put all the
weight on? Yeah, I think so.
What kind of testing they do for that
fight? Uh, they test you for everything,
but did they test you for everything
at the wanes? Nah. See, see me.
Um, I'm with the Vada during
the full testing tools.
They show up at six
o'clock in the morning,
the whole deal and they
can test out. They,
they can test me right now and if they
wanted to tell him I'd be waiting outside
right now. It's cool. Cause I know
I'm good. So, but when he fought, um,
Vladimir and he got all big, what did
they do with any kind of wide testing?
I don't know what type of contract,
what they signed for on a
contract when they fight contract.
But I know me when I'm in training camp,
they come whenever they had come six
o'clock in the morning and turn around and
come at six o'clock at
night if they wanted to.
That's a point of diminishing returns
when you get too much muscle, right? Like
yeah, it can make you stronger, but that,
that's going to need a lot of oxygen
too. And if your body's not used to it,
if you, if this is over the
course of like a year or two,
all the sudden you got this
extra muscle like is, do you,
are you a fan of guys lifting a lot of
weights and lifting up lightweight? Yeah,
the right way just to stay strong. Yeah.
Well I have a vendor Holyfield we're
scheduling Evander Holyfield. I'm excited.
Huge Evander Holyfield fan.
But he was one of the rare guys that
put on the mass and moved up from
cruiserweight to heavyweight and
fucking still never got tired.
I mean Evander never got tired cause he,
they put the work crazy work ethic and
he was a guy that got thick and muscular,
but it didn't slow him down.
It enhanced him, you know,
especially when you get into
like the Tyson fights like that,
that muscle didn't hold him pack
at all and he was fucking jacked.
I mean he was he comparison to
cruiserweight Evander Holyfield.
Do you look at heavyweight of random
old like the Riddick Bowe fights.
D D is scroll up a lot. Fuck. He
was just cut though. Yes. Chiseled.
Yeah. So that's what
Joshua said, dude, cut,
cut down a little bit and she
has a weapon, gets a get mobile.
Do you think this was something that he
got mad at Lennox Lewis for saying that
he needs to change camps? Do
you think that makes sense?
Maybe just he should sit down with his
team and figure out where they went wrong
at. I don't think about, I don't
think you should change everything.
The word was that he had gotten knocked
out in training. That was a true,
you heard
that as well by Joey. Well, Terrence
Crawford heard it. Shit's got to be real.
That's what I'm saying. I'm just
going, I'm going. I'm Twitter now.
I want to say it feels real or fake.
I'm just saying. I heard you heard it.
Yeah, but you know,
most people heard the rumors go around
and everybody here and it's not even true
because that could happen. Right?
Like Richard Gere with that juror
bulb his ass. Remember that one? You
ever heard that? But you never heard
that he said a jerboa PD. You heard it,
right? Yeah. Tell him to tell him
the rumor. I just heard the rumor.
I don't know. Kids were kids. Um,
there was a rumor that Richard Gere
had to go to the hospital. Get a,
we'll take out of his ass. Now
I grew up in the East coast.
My friend Eddie grew up in California.
He heard the same story. I was like,
this is the same God damn rubber.
Like how this room we get across the
country with the same age, no internet.
The rumor made it all the way across
the country when we were in high school.
So was it true or not? Probably not.
I think you'd get out
of trouble out yourself.
You don't need to go to the
hospital. You know is not,
not worth the embarrassment.
You'll take some time to go to the store
and buy some tweezers, but you're, uh,
you don't need to go to the hospital.
Just get a mirror and some tweezers.
We could handle this. We don't need
to let everybody know our business.
The other one was rod
Stewart, rod Stewart.
There was a rumor where in high
school it was boom, pre high school,
the rod Stewart had swallowed a bunch of
Jews and had to go to the hospital and
get his stomach pumped.
It was probably some guy who rod Stewart
fucked his girlfriend and he started
riding the bad guy. And
that probably is true.
I don't think so because I
think when I hosted fear factor,
we made people drink
calm. They had to drink.
They had a drink donkey com you could
drink it and you can drink a lot of it and
you're fine. I don't think you
have to go to the hospital.
My experience on fear
factor, it taught me that a,
I don't believe that rod Stewart
ever had that real problem. Hey,
so did you ever do anything that
uh, I ate attempts. I ate some shit.
They wouldn't let me try any of the stunts
because of insurance purposes or you
know, they had,
cause the insurance doesn't let
the host just try it out for fun.
Like I wanted to drive some of
the cars off buildings and shit,
but they wouldn't let me do,
we had one where they hit a
ramp off the top of a building.
They hit a ramp and the ramp flipped the
car through the air and they flew and
they landed on these cardboard boxes.
They stack these cardboard boxes
up like several stories high.
And that's how they would get these cars
to land softly. So the car would boom,
hit the cardboard box and
just slowly sink down.
And then they would use a crane,
flipped the car over and then
they could use that car again.
It didn't even get damaged. Wow. So these
people would fly this fucking car off.
It looked like the craziest amusement
park ride ever. And you wanted to do all,
fuck yeah, I want you to get it man.
I'm like, come on, let me do that one.
It looks easy. I'm like, I'll do
it for the promo. Like God man,
I be cool with jumping
out the plane. Yeah,
we didn't do any of that but we did
have people bungee cord jump off of a
fucking helicopter. That was crazy.
We had a people with a cord there was
attached to a helicopter and then they
were hooked up to a tree and they had
an unlocked themselves in the tree.
They had all got a ring of keys.
He had to find the right key
in a certain amount of time.
And then when they did it,
they unlocked and trying.
They went flying through the air cause
they were attached to a bungee cord and
the bungee cord was underneath
the helicopter and it
would go fucking launching
them out into the middle of this
crazy Canyon. I was like, Oh my God,
someone's gonna die. Someone's
going to die. This isn't worth it.
This job's not worth it.
There was a couple of times where I
thought someone was going to die. Hey,
that's crazy. Stupid. Ridiculous.
I'm glad. I'm glad we got through it.
When nobody getting hurt, I'm sorry.
[inaudible] came up with the uh,
the stunts and all that. There was a
bunch of people, they had a whole team.
There's teams that people that
came up with eating stunts.
There were the beat team stunt guys,
and then the AA team
stunt guys was the first,
first stunt and then there was the, the C,
which was like the big championship
finale thing. It's ridiculous show.
Last time, man, I used to watch that
show all the time. I'll have the time.
I can't believe it's real. I
watch it to this day. I was like,
is that really me? What
is that? So long ago. Uh,
I remember I used to watch
jackass, jackasses. Amazing.
Those guys are alive, Steve. Oh,
so healthy. You're fine. Come on.
Making a fourth movie.
They're rolling that dice.
They're rolling that die. Someone's
going to die. Damn. That's crazy. That's,
I only seen pimps of that.
Johnny Knoxville was a movie
star for awhile. Right.
Cause he's still doing big movies.
I think so he was doing big movies and
then he was still willing to let a bowl
hit him. He put a blindfold on,
stood in front of a bowl and the bull
just fucking launched him through the air
blindfolded. Shit. That's the dumbest
[inaudible] it's like the girl
bus guys got fucked up, man.
I mean that is theirs. They're taking
some beatings. I'm, what do we do? Laugh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
See what you do is control
who gets fucked up. Right.
That's what I like about boxing.
When I watched boxing
express at the highest level,
it's like one guy is controlling who
gets fucked up, you know? Yeah. Red,
the other guy liking or not, whether
the other guy likes it or not.
What was that?
The Mexican gentleman that you fought
recently that was talking a lot of shit
and stopped him Benevidez
Benevides, right? Yeah.
That seemed like a particularly satisfying
one for you because it was a lot of
shit talking, leading up
to that fight for years.
There's certain times when you watch
guys talk shit and I go sodden,
this is not a good idea. But it
just came out of [inaudible] and
nowhere, like I never
said nothing to that dude.
Never did nothing until that dude like,
and he just out the blue just
for years, like I'm ducking.
I'm like, dude, you went up and wait.
I'm at one 40 like when I was at one
35 he was talking about fighting me.
He was at one 40 I got up to one 40 he
wanted a little fight and then he moved
up in weight and I'm like, dude,
like you're nobody for
me to be worried about.
So then it got to the point
where he was like, Oh,
well they made me an offer to fight
you and you talked me and this.
So he started telling
everybody I ducked them.
I been ducking them since one 40
so in a press conference I said,
did y'all ever and offer me or
him a fight to fight each other?
And I was like no.
So I was so worried come up with
that cause like well it don't matter.
We fighting right now. So all right.
It was a good fight. This good fight
is a good fight too to showcase you,
you know, particularly the knockout. And
that was a beautiful combination man.
When we clipped him right. And then
he gets up and then you put him away.
When you watch a fight like that where
you have a guy who talks shit and then
you wind up fucking him up. Was
it ever more satisfying? Oh yeah.
Cause you seem to enjoy it.
It's like Hey the best fighters enjoy
putting a beating on someone. Yeah,
of course.
Going into the fight,
I had to calm my emotions down
cause of the anger. Right.
Because I really want the hurt that
dude, you know. So going into the fight,
I got to keep reminding
myself, stay calm, relaxed,
don't go in there and do nothing stupid.
Cause this is what he wants you to do.
And you been here before, you
know, this is nothing new.
You didn't have people talk crazy to
you, but not to the level that he did.
But you didn't have people
talking crazy until you,
so that's why when I first got
in there, I was being patient,
taking my time and just filling them out.
You know, cause he's long, he's tall,
he's long, got some speed on
him, but he's a naturally uh,
counter-puncher.
So it was like I wasn't going to go in
there and be careless and get countered
because I already knew
what he wanted to do.
Okay. So when you, when you see a guy, a
guy like that, and you're fighting him,
what, what is the strap like?
This is a different strategy than a normal
fighter because of the length and the
counterpunch mobility. So you
have to adjust, right. So what is,
what was your plan going in there?
Well, see me,
I got long orange to be in
a division and my height.
So I was just like, all right,
just pick them apart, you know?
And then once you go
into your combinations,
make sure you throw more than once
because you're going to counter that first
one properly.
And when you watch the fight, you feel
like that's exactly what you're planting,
preparing for right now. When
you see Errol Spence, excuse me,
we see Errol Spence jr.
Does he represent to you like the one of
the best of the upcoming guys that are,
that are possibly on your radar? At least?
I really can't say that.
You know, because arrow,
this is the first real big test
that he's up against. You know,
um,
his last fight was with, uh, Mikey
Garcia. That was a good fight. I mean,
that was a good test.
It's true. You know, uh,
Mikey came from, what, one 26?
No. Um, he's what, five, six? When
you see the two of them at the Wayans and
you really could see the difference in
the size of arrow. I mean, Earl's ripped.
Right. You know, so that's, that's why
I say you really can't tell with
my DRCs, don't get me wrong.
Mikey's a hell of a fighter, you know?
But that was his first fight in the
division. Uh, he's a smaller guy.
He's short and his arms is shorter.
Arrow, taller, longer, bigger,
you know, so faster. So
you, he really couldn't,
I really couldn't see what I
was trying to see. So Mike,
Mikey went up just because it
was a big fight. Right? Right.
Is he going to stay there
do you think? Or is he, yes,
I believe he's going to fight Danny
Garcia. Oh, interesting. Interesting.
There's so many different outlets for
boxing now. You know, there's PBC,
there's Fox, there's, you know,
ESPN is putting on high caliber fights
now too. Right. It's very interesting.
But HBO is out of the game. Doesn't that
feel weird? It does bend that, that,
that was the GoTo channel to watch a
boxing when I was coming up, when he,
people you had on Showtime was Mike
Tyson and it was the best commentary crew
twos, Jim Lampley, max Kellerman, Roy
Jones, jr or sometimes George Foreman.
You know, Larry merchant America
was the, was doing that. Yeah, man.
Emmanuel Stewart and Harold Letterman
would come in between rounds and give you
his score. It was fucking great. I
missed that. Yeah. Don't you miss that?
I mean, Harold Letterman, rest in
peace. He passed away recently. Um,
didn't he did it? Yeah, he passed. Um,
but I, I missed that man, Jim Lampley.
It was fucking great and max Kellerman
was great. It's like you don't have that,
there's not a commentary team
like that right now in boxing.
My Ron not to the,
to the level of why don't
they have expertise go over
to one of these streaming
services like the zone or
ESPN or something. It just
seems like that's the team,
right? Yeah. Well, Andre ward,
Andre Ward's fantastic at it.
He's coming down here to have
him on, uh, Tim [inaudible].
Tim Bradley coming along pretty good
too. Yes. Very good. Yeah. I mean,
he's taken, he's taking look like he's
taking that role of a Teddy Atlas. Yeah.
It's like he got all of
that energy. Yes. Well,
Teddy's fucking what a character. I know
he'd get it. Is
daddy. I rather get out there and
fight. He was screaming. I was kidding.
Fucking scared. It's funny.
I, he'll say on, on here,
these judges deed to be fired.
Yeah, don't give a fuck.
He doesn't give a fuck. You got skill
notorious at bad decisions and he's right.
He's right. Sometimes, you know
he's right. He's wrong about that.
Jeff Warner flight, the
Jeff Warren Pacquiao fight
watched when he freaked out.
Is that one of the ones who
freaked out when he freaked out?
I watched when I first watched it,
you know, listening to the commentary,
I was like, man, back, y'all whooping
him. You know what I mean? Why they,
why they, why they, why
they cheat them. You know?
Cause I wanted to fight pack y'all
because I was the next in line,
of course the champion. So of
course I'm rooting for Peggy.
I don't want any cause that's
a bigger fight. But after
watching the fight again, I was like,
they not saying nothing
about autumn shots.
Jeff Horn was hitting Pat Galloway and
he was just brutally bullying them,
roughing him up. Uh, they can
say all he was being dirty.
Sometimes your head bud, but it's a
fight that's going to happen, you know?
But he was real life man handling pack.
Y'all like pushing them all around and
you see Keith Thurman couldn't even do
that. Yeah. You know, and
beat Keith Thurman at 40 years old
like God damn, this guy is great.
I mean, just look at his career
w eight different weight classes,
world titles in eight
different weight classes,
40 years old beats Keith Thurman who,
who's in his prime. Right. Crazy.
I mean w what a man man, what a world
champion and he should have turned bright.
Dan's the time on that one. Crazy.
Any foreign inspire. It's both of them
bursts. And I thought Keith
was going to pick up on it,
but pack y'all was only fighting,
fighting the end of the round.
Like Keith would come on strong at the
beginning of the round and they'd be
like, all right, Keith
winning, winning this round.
And then Pat geologists were like,
sure, yeah, pop, pop, pop, pop.
And then Keith will be like, [inaudible].
You're like, Aw man,
I ain't even seen the phone when he
dropped him with that right hook early in
the first. You're like,
Oh right shit. Yeah, no,
it was like a,
he jumped in with that laughing and
followed by like a straight right.
It was crazy. Yeah, it was crazy. It's
like wow, what was his shoulder? Yup.
That's his plans. Yep. They was showing
him, hitting other fighters with it.
The same thing, who boom, boom.
He also has a unique style.
The leaping [inaudible] if he
came in with that shit on you
[inaudible] Oh man. Nah,
but I give, I take my hat
off to pack y'all like,
do you think it's possible that
you could get a crack at him now?
Cause now there he's, you know, he's
in the hunt right now. I wouldn't,
I wouldn't say,
I wouldn't say so because I was in the
mentions and talk to fight pack y'all
since 2014 and we was in
the same promotional company
and they couldn't make it
happen. So you think it's because
he's not interested in that?
I don't think he was interested in it
because his coach mentioned numerous
times. He didn't want him to fight me.
He wanted him to stay away from me.
So I don't think they was
interested. Yeah. Well,
I could see that
this stage of his career.
But you know Keith Thurman is a
fucking murderer puncher. Right.
Which what was one of the reasons why
it's more impressive that he beat him.
And so who are they talking about?
Patio matching up with next.
He chasing the Mayweather.
So why not right.
Come on. I know you love money.
He was saying that he thinks Floyd's
out of money already cause he says Floyd
spend so much money. He's probably already
out of it. Well he spammed money too.
I think pet cows spam where money named
Floyd and when everybody else Oh that's
right cause he's got like 50 people
that he just has supported. Yeah.
I mean he's a, he's an interesting
guy man cause he's so friendly. Right.
You know like Pat even like
when people are trash talking,
he was like smiling and then he gets
in that rang kick your ass later.
Different. Fuck you do.
What's the gypsy that Rose like this
is a whole different set of rules he's
flying with like Keith Thurman talking
about he going to crucify him and stuff
like that. And he just like don't say
that. Yeah, it got crucified. Yeah.
He's the best to [inaudible] lucky enough.
I like he's a killer pool players.
There's no that about pack
yo know like world class.
Like he could play pool professionally.
Me tune. Really? Yeah. You could play.
Oh we got play in that. I heard you.
You got got some little personal stents.
Pretty good. You're good? Yeah.
Okay. Well what do you play?
Whatever you want to play. You play
like nine ball, 10 ball, whatever. Okay,
we'll play it. Cool. So if I leave
five balls on the table, you owe me.
If farmer your balls on five balls on
the tee, my boy playing eight ball,
you can't Bay. That's nonsense. It's a
nonsense game. Hey, belts a silly game.
You're trying to get me leave
my balls on the table. No,
I'm saying if you take
your balls, if I win. Okay.
And you still got five balls on your
table. Five. Five are your balls.
If you, you got seven
balls if you can't a ball.
So the only way that I went,
explain what you're saying. Okay.
So you guys seven balls.
So start if I beat you and you still
got five of your balls on the table.
Okay, then you, Oh, Oh what? What?
So if you mean if you break and
run out and I don't get a shot. No,
that's seven ball. Then you get all
the balls. Yeah, that's seven ball.
If I have five balls left and
you went, yeah, what does that,
what kind of weird gaze? You
ain't get it. I'm not getting it.
So if I win and you still got five balls
on the table. Okay, then what happens?
You owe. I owe what but see if
we play time ball or 10 ball,
you can't win if there's five balls,
nine ball and Tim ball, that's different.
But that's what we were
saying. Yeah. Yeah.
So you were saying like fly eight ball,
but I don't like playing that cause
that's tricky. Yeah, it's tricky. You play
as a strategy. Yeah. You got
to learn how to get out. Yeah,
I'll hit all of them and missed
the last one. Play ball though.
That's a cool like ball. It's
okay. But it's a simpler game.
And you popped me for the last,
yeah, I leave you hanging if fuck up.
Leave that 10 ball wobbling in the hole.
Like he didn't did all this for
nothing. I've done that before.
It's very heartbreaking. Very
heartbreaking. That's the worst way.
Using games where it's like
all that for nothing and the,
and the guys. Thank you for cleaning up.
That's a game that no one
wants to lose to a girl.
It gets hilarious watching dudes play
pool against women. When women are good,
they panic. They start getting nervous.
Like there's something
about losing to a girl.
It's almost like getting your ass kicked
by a girl. Some of them call honest.
Seeing some girls at the pool
hall. Oh yes. Taken a lot of money.
Oh for sure. Yeah, there's,
there's like elite women players.
You know what I do to the eliminate
that. What I just be like, nah,
I'm only childlike. Especially where
you watching them and then they try to,
Hey, I got an, I'd be like, yeah
y'all, y'all can play. Cause it ain't,
it ain't for me to be getting washed up
by no female. Well and any professional.
I've played a lot of professionals like
cause it's one of the weird sports that
you can enter into a tournament and you,
you could be a guy who you know as a
full time job and you might wind up
matching up with like effort. Rayez I
was like the greatest player of all time.
You might meet him in the first
round of a tournament. You both,
all you have to do is pay your fee
and then you pay your entry fee.
You join in just like everybody else
and you're playing like a world champ.
Like the Terrance Crawford
a pool. I'm like Whoa.
And you could just be some regular
dude playing Efron Rez, but it's cool.
You can be like, man, I lost it.
We had the greatest lost one of
the greatest of all time. Yeah.
I've played a bunch of like great play.
I played Mike Siegel before I got
to play a bunch of great players.
Get my ass kicked by him. You will
professional pool player. No, no.
I'm quite a bit like below. Like
if you had like a Manny Pacquiao,
he could play professional. He would
beat me. I'm like one notch below them.
Probably like a notch below that,
two notch below them. But man,
he like plays in tournaments.
He gambles. They call them.
Unfortunately they call them the cow
cause they're always milking them.
[inaudible] cause he's real high level
pool players, man. I mean he's good man.
He's too busy with running the
country. It means a fucking Senator.
On top of that, he's one of the best
boxers in the world and on top of that,
he's got a family. He doesn't have time
to be at the pool hall 10 hours a day.
All those psychopaths that are like
world champions, they play pool eight,
10 hours a day. They play all day
long, all day long. You go there,
you'll find them. That's where they're
at. You say you go there, you're fine.
They're there every fucking day.
Everybody that I know that's like an
elite world class pool player like Mika
Immonen and you know these
kind of guys, you go there,
they're there at the goddamn pool every
day. No money in that shit though.
You think there's no money in UFC,
there's no money in that shit.
There's a lot of money on poker.
There is how to play. I know,
right? [inaudible] poker, it seemed
like, uh, my friend Anthony G or Donald,
he a directs those. I used
to direct those poker shows.
He said what changed it is when you had
the TV shows where you could see the
person's hand.
So like we were all playing the folks at
home could see what I have and they can
see what you have, but we didn't know
what we have. So they're all in on it.
So the fuck, how's he gonna play
that? How's it going to play this?
So it made it way more
interesting than just watching.
Because if you were watching
three guys play poker,
you would have no idea
whose hands or what.
But when you're at home and you
watch on TV, you get to see the hand.
And I still don't know how to play.
Yeah, I don't know how to play either,
but I just be seeing people with a
poker face all in, don't have nothing,
and then this dude with a
good Hage just put like,
Oh, his hands
look. Just be like, okay,
take that risk.
Oh man. Something cool about that. Right?
Like a bullshitty. It's bullshitting.
You know? There's something
about that, like the hustle.
There's the thing about poker that
doesn't exist in anything else.
The psychological hustle, that's why
they call it the poker face. Yep.
That's a lady Gaga song, bro. Pop, pop,
pop or somebody looking all
like looking all sad like, yeah,
you got a bad hand knowing you got a
good here. Yup. It's tricky. Then they,
Hey you
all in. Okay.
Plus I found gamblers when they're around
each other all the time and then just
fucking, that's all they do is gamble
and read signs and check each other out.
They'd probably have a like a highly tuned
sense of someone bullshitting. Right.
Highly tuned. Oh, there's
something going on behind his eyes,
but that's why they wear them
glasses. Yeah. You know what?
I've always like love watching.
Scary to get good at his chest. Just
seems like it would eat your fucking time.
CTS. Do you play high?
Yeah, I taught him I replay.
He taught me to not beat him.
Beat him the same at the
same day he taught you?
He just taught me how to move the pieces
and I'll be like, huh? Jesus. Yeah.
Wow. That's interesting. So
women are national rights,
so I'm one Monica fifth right now. Do
this age nationally ranked? No, I'm saying
we on the international show. Right?
The whole world is watching. I'll let
these do beat you. Let him beat you. Watch
this up, get his confidence.
Hey, but this is how I do do it.
There's some fights. Well,
I want him to play test so I can
so he can use his mind. Right.
[inaudible] that's okay.
All right. All right.
The whole camp he used in his mind,
you use this miles. I'm like, okay.
All right. So he'd come out there and
he had great performance. So I'm like,
okay. All right. That's another strategy
to try to get him to do better. Right.
But there are some mornings, I'm tell
you about this, last morning we had,
you know, let me beat him. I just beat
him anytime. I really want to win,
I win. [inaudible] come downstairs, right?
So he comes downstairs and
in his boxers and shit,
this old terrace Crawford, look,
look in here violent. Hey, good
morning or morning, let's play. All right.
I'm kicking his ass. Right. It
meant he'd get mad. You could see,
you could see it in his face. Right?
So he started making these different,
but now man, you can't do that. No man,
yes I kiss a kid. No, you can't do that.
But you know, you can't
do that after a while.
You just gotta kind of fear for
your life a little bit. Cause
no. Yeah. I like Ali big fit in with
this duty chest man. It's funny.
It's funny when he's
losing, they beat me. He beat me that
day. I didn't want to play me again.
I was on, I see it in your face right now.
Oh yeah. You can see reliving it
because he just caught me off guard.
It's just like, you know what?
I mean like I come downstairs and eat
some breakfast and he's talking about
that's plate. He got it
ready and everything. Oh,
I'm making stupid. I'm like, damn man,
I ain't see that. Like fuck. So he,
when he won't play me, but
the next time he played me,
I watched them killed them
so, so bad to where he,
he don't even want to play me no more.
It's funny is that's one thing
that champions have all champions.
They hate losing any
game or any like Jordan,
they said if you beat him playing pool,
who fucking hate you
didn't want to talk to you.
Didn't want to until he could beat
you again until he got you again. See,
my thing is we have a lot of people
that want to play the game, right?
So I'm, I don't play the game
like I used to. I used to play in,
I used to beat them all, but once my
nephew got good, I stopped playing.
I'm like, man, your game here, I ain't
got time the best just sitting on game.
And you know,
like video games like Xbox two K
and you can't fucking those kids,
those kids that don't have
their responsibilities,
they don't have children.
They don't, they don't have,
they have nothing but time.
They get too good at
those goddamn thing. Good.
So was lose your life
trying to chase him. So now,
so now it gets to the point where
I just watched him play. So,
so we had this dude named chairs at that.
Oh man. So,
so chance we got shit
core and we got Chucky,
they all like to play and we got Kenny.
So Kenny was playing Chucky choke you
and chance was always going at it.
We each other and uh,
Kenny was beating Chuckie and he was
just rubbing in his face and it was just
like, you can see how mad he
was. Like, and this dude Chuggy,
he's the one that always be
like joking around and stuff.
It's all fun and games and you like,
you could just see, he was like,
why is you even talking if
you not playing like, Hey,
it gets so bad in the house man
too. You have to put the game up.
You guys have like moments where you
don't want them to play games and things
like that. Like during camp, like
you just want to just arrest. No, no.
That's relaxation. Relaxing. Yeah,
but video games are a little,
they get your tense. That's
why he took the gay gay.
He did so it get so tense.
People were to fight each other.
People get in arguments. One want to
do to get mad at other dude like ah,
you mad like man, shut up man.
That's why we sparring when we get to
the gym. Huh? How about that Tiberius?
Be funny as shit, man. It can, it
can cause problems too. Oh sure.
Well a bunch of competitive dudes all
training together and then you play
something competitive that makes
you angry if you lose. Yeah. Yeah.
Recipe for disaster. Right. And
they don't care. They don't care.
They don't care an hour and they just
like whatever. I still want to play.
It's like a big daycare.
That's basically what it is. Big D me,
I'm the oldest guy to
start cussing at home.
You can't eat,
don't you? Come out your room,
get up for your duties, dishes.
Oh bad. It seems like you guys
are having a good time. Amaz
it's, it's fun. Campus campus is
fine. It's hard work and it's hard.
But at the same time, you know,
we work as work and then we
try to come home and you know,
clear our head and not just
be so mentally drained over,
over thinking about the fight. Right.
So we want it to be fun
at the end of the day.
Do you have like a,
a mental coach or is there anybody
you've ever worked with that's like, uh,
like where you've tried to
do visualization work or
formulate a game plan or is
it just,
just go out there and get it done?
Just get it done. No need, no need.
Like my mental is so strong.
Like from what I have overcome and
been through in my heart entire lives,
it's like nothing's going to
break me. That's my mental,
like if that couldn't break
me, you not going to break me.
I mean in terms of the way your
childhood growing up. Yeah.
Like everything that I went
through. Irreplaceable. Right.
People that have gone through
Mike, Mike Tyson,
like many great fighters have gone through
hardship when they're younger. That,
Whoa, that, that ability to endure.
It's not, I wouldn't say when I was
younger and it's still going through,
still going through. I still go
through a lot. A lot. How so?
Like it seemed like
before all my big fights,
somebody die or my family, you know,
like my grandpa just died the day
before yesterday. Sorry to hear them.
Yeah. But I'm here, you
know what I mean? Yeah.
I'm about to going training camp and
prepare for my next fight, you know?
So it was just like things
always happening. Right.
But at the same time I got a job to do
and I'm going to still be focused and
nothing's going to distract me. Now
will you go on a training camp with
a date in mind or would you just,
but do they, but you haven't,
nothing's been signed yet, right?
Nothing has been signed yet.
So do you just sort of go in and get the
wheels move in and then just get ready
to ramp up? Like how do you determine
when you ramp up your training camp?
If you're like, say if you're
getting back into training camp now,
but you don't know when the fight is
going to be scheduled. So how do you,
how do you approach it in the beginning?
No, I don't, I don't,
I wouldn't necessarily necessarily say
I'm getting in training camp right now
because I'm not like, my training
camp is six to seven weeks.
So you get forward ready
to get into training
camp? No, I wouldn't even say that. I'm
just saying in general, okay. You know,
you're not getting ready. Right. State
work now I stay working. Of course,
you know,
now when you're not, when
you're not in the gent, well,
when you were in the gym, but
you're not training for a fight,
are you still doing all the
strength conditioning stuff?
Yeah. Here and there. Yeah.
And not to the same intensity,
but just to keep moving.
Right.
And so you do that just to make sure
that you preserve your body and don't get
injured and things along those lines.
So when you think of it in terms of camp
like that as the roughest experience
you're going through it, right?
You're going through how many nine weeks
that would you say you prefer? Seven,
seven weeks, seven weeks.
So that those seven weeks there is when
you are pushing it to the limit and then
everything else is more
like a maintaining thing.
We like stair steppers,
we've got a precap and then once we're
in camp it's like this don't, don't,
don't, don't, don't, don't, don't. And
you know what those steps are, right?
So when we get to the, to the end
of camp, we already at the highest,
highest step. So that way when we go
to, to the fight, we already at the end.
And so this is planned out in
the amount of rounds you do.
The amount of running every week, every
week is something added on every week.
If it's for around six round, eight
rounds, 10 12, two minutes, we do minutes.
You know,
what's amazing about this conversation
is if you are a young up and coming boxer
in, you know,
1982 or something like that and you
want to know how Marvin Hagler did it.
There was no podcast, right?
There was no like Marvin Hagler breaking
down how he does his training camp and
talking all about it.
But today kids can watch you and
they can see what you're doing.
And I guarantee just listening to you
talk about realizing how hard Floyd worked
and you work it out,
you wanted to work out even harder
and all the crazy shit you're doing.
Like people right now lacing up
the shoes right now and fire it up,
running out the door thinking I
gotta work like Terrance. I have to,
you know that is one of the coolest
things has to be about being a world
champion is that you are the guy
now, you know when you were a kid,
I'm sure you had like those
ring magazine posters and shit.
Like you're that guy now,
right? That's gotta be crazy.
Some kid right now who's
like six years old.
I was just getting the golden gloves
and he's looking up at his bedroom wall.
Silver gloves, golden gloves,
the golden gloves. 18 yeah, we use yours,
several gloves. And when your jewelry,
silver gloves,
it doesn't sound as good.
Yeah. Boxing, amateur boxing,
kids getting an amateur boxing. Definitely
heroes. You're one of them, man.
I mean that's gotta be, you
gotta be a cool feeling.
Oh yeah man. I love it.
I love it. And when I go,
when I go to them little little smokers
or I'm little national tournaments and
see all the little kids run up to me
[inaudible] and I'd be like, what up?
I go grab it all. That's awesome
grandpa. They head mess around with him.
And if you're out there, a
wrestling tournament, pupil like,
yo your terrorist car. I'd be like,
yeah, what's up? What's your name?
And they'd be like, dude, like man, you,
you real cool. Like I'd be like, man,
yeah man. What's up? That's amazing.
So they all gravitate to me.
Was there someone that you met
when you first met them when you're
like,
I can't even believe that I'm sitting
there with Evander Holyfield or someone
like that.
Someone real famous where you couldn't
believe you were actually being around
them.
Do you want to have to say Roy Jones
Jones? Because I never was like
a big fan boy. I'll always be like,
Aw man, they just humans like me.
But when I seen Roy for the
first time I was like Paul,
that's Roy Jones jr like
I met Floyd Mayweather
but this Roy Jones jr like
yeah it was just crazy.
He was real cool and you
know I was just like damn,
I didn't want to be like all
like shines to out like damn.
Like I met sugar Ray linner when I was
at amateur and it didn't feel the same.
It was just like man, that sugar. Right.
Cause it's a different era cause it was,
you didn't watch them fight watching
Roy Jones, man when I was a kid,
when he was in his prime,
he would lead with a left hook
and he's like more than a jab.
He was just whip that left hook at dudes
and they didn't know what the fuck to
do with that. That speed was
preposterous. So fast. Woo.
Roy was doing stuff to people
that made you just go, wow.
Like he's not even doing the same
thing they're doing right. He's like,
he's on another dimension is a
different record. Speed. You know,
he was so fast,
like max Kellerman had this incredible
ramp once about just realizing how good
Roy Jones was in his prime is, it wasn't
like he wasn't around great fighters,
but they couldn't do shit to him.
Nah, he was around world champions,
but he was lighting them on fire.
Right. It was crazy. And you know,
all good things come to an end. It only
lasted for, you know, X amount of years.
I mean, what was the best years
of his championship reign?
But he was untouchable,
untouchable, untouchable.
When knocked out Virgil Hill with
that body shot. Why? You know,
he's like God to him.
One punch. And when he,
when he put his hands behind his back
and still knocked down Jamestown,
I mean he,
when he dropped his hands like this and
James Tony does it too and he leaps in
and drops him at one duty. Knocked
out what? His hands behind his back.
Who was that dude? I forgot
what it was on the ropes. Yeah,
put his hands behind his back.
The dude moves forward and
drops him and knocks him out.
It's like this is a movie scene,
right? This is a real life.
No one does that in real life. Roy
Jones was having fun with people. Yeah.
He was having fun with his entertainment.
He was incredible how fast he was.
But like I got him, man,
I didn't met people like Roy.
He's a fan of me. It's amazing.
And it's like, dude,
like I'll be like so
starstruck. It's like, man,
I'm a fan of you and he's a fan of you.
You're a fan of me. Wow. Like today,
today, so happy. I was on
Instagram and I was like, um,
I wouldn't pass LL cool J cause we was
listened to some old school music and I I
like dang LOL. Got an Instagram. So I
clicked on him and he's following me.
I sell Bo look,
LL coolJ following me on Instagram.
It's just crazy just to think of all the
people that you like grew up admiring
and like you a fan of and for
you to see them fan of you.
It's like damn like Iverson. Iverson.
Wow. And he came up to me and he was
more happy to see me then I wasn't him.
I tear his car for it. Oh man.
You know mom. Wow. And I was like,
I was just sitting there looking
at him like this, our IRA's
[inaudible] like so it's crazy
like seeing all those, you know,
celebrities and all time greats,
that's big fans of mine
and it's like fuck,
does it wear off or do
you still freak out?
I still freak out some times
I still freak out sometimes.
Like it just depends on the person.
Like, fuck, like damn right,
like Snoop or something like that.
Like Snoop too. I know I met Snoop,
I'll be like, damn, like fuck.
Like that's when you know that you made
it to a certain level and yo yo uh,
professional sports that
everybody watching you. Yeah.
Well you know,
and that's one more thing that's beautiful
about you meeting those little kids
is that they can realize
like, Oh, Terrence Crawford's
a man, right? He's a man,
man. He's a superstar and he's a champion
and I see him on TV, but he's a man.
He's right here. He kept me in
the headlock. Right? Oh shit.
We're playing together.
He's a nice guy. Oh,
he's a person because you see someone
that's achieved a certain level of status
and championship reign and you
see him on TV knocking people out.
That doesn't even seem like a
real person when you're a kid.
I that can't be a real person. Right.
And then you're there and
then he's shaking his head.
He's like, what the fuck?
This is crazy.
So you changed that kid's world
like his idea of what the future is.
Idea what a person is. A person
is Terrence Crawford as a person.
I'm a person too. I got
just got to work hard
and it's crazy because like
a lot of a lot of people,
they would see me and they'd be like,
we are your body and we
entourage like they be.
They be having questions that,
yeah. And I'd just be like, nah man,
I'm a regular person. They'd be like,
man, why you ain't gonna be on TV?
Like Floyd Mayweather? Black man
ain't for me, man. I'm, I'm chill.
They'd be like, Oh well
where are your cars?
Like they'd be just acting all kinds
of crazy stuff and I just be like, nah,
man, you live where you grew
up. Right. Wow. That's crazy.
And everybody's cool.
Everybody. Nobody gets jealous.
The fact that your [inaudible],
you always gonna have that
no matter where you go,
you always gonna have the jealousy and
the people that NVU people want loans.
Right. You just gotta you just
got to move different. Yeah.
You just got to move
differently. Do you need, do you,
what kind of cars you Rob? I drive old
schools. Old schools. Like what kind of,
I got some Monte Carlo.
Oh, Oh, that's right. I saw you and looked
like a grand national, but of a grand
national. I said Monte Carlo.
That's a Monte Carlo. Oh,
is this a souped up Monte Carlo?
Nice. This is all original.
I just put the ramps on it. Oh, the
soup. That one is the silver one. The 87.
Oh, what is that? Another Monte-Carlo.
Oh, you're a Monte Carlo guy. Yeah.
I love Monte Carlo's back in the day.
Like the 70s like 70 Monte Carlo's. Ooh,
those are so pretty.
Ain't nothing like the 80 [inaudible] 87
that's probably because you're younger
than me. Super sport. Me, I'm,
I'm like, I get from muscle cars.
I get as high as 71 with a Barracuda and
then I drop off. Yeah. Everything else.
Like I need 65 to 70 71 that's only,
only Barracuda and challenger. That's
it. Everything else fell apart by 71.
What about the, uh, the, a Oldsmobile?
They made some cool shit.
They made some cool shit,
but it's just not as good as like the
sixties sixties and the 1970 cars like 70
Chevelle Chevelle come on, seven job top.
The drop. The problem
with drop top is the O,
the weekly or you know the like
there's a lot of body flicks to it,
whether you don't get the rigidity that
you feel and like the solid hard top
muscle car. Right. You know what?
I'd love those old cars, man.
They have something to them, right?
Nay costs a shit ton of money
if you get, if you get one as all
the original, Oh yeah. Everything.
The paint still like, man,
you bought this car to put it in
the garage for 30 years. Dude,
I saw Sarah kudo that was for
sale for over a million dollars.
$1 million for a car that was
like $30 30,000 not even right.
Didn't we talk about this does in
like five grand when his brand new,
something crazy like that. Now
it's $1 million. I got a J Lindell,
I don't know one of those knuckleheads
that likes everything perfect and
original. There's certain dudes like
with the original numbers matching,
look with a V I N number
matches the tires.
These are the original tires
from 1960 [inaudible] paperwork.
You better go slow around the
corner with those shitty tires.
Everything original means
everything's shitty.
No shitty drum brakes
and shitty suspension.
And I like the size. I used to eyes, uh,
get up and watch them car auctions.
Oh yeah, the Meacham. Yeah.
That kind of shape. Just loved
those. Just to look at the cars. God,
if you have a ton of money and you're
there, that shit could be real bad. Yeah.
Like if you're one of those dudes,
it's like a collector and you
see all those cars moving by.
Like I want that one to 55 off. 55
Chevy, right. Oh my goodness. Yeah.
This, there's some, I mean, I'm
just a big fan of those shapes.
Those shapes are the 1960 shapes
because there's something about the car,
they just nailed it. They just knew how
to make a car look beautiful back then.
And it was enabled to build sturdy.
Like nowadays, you bump a car,
your big old tent pumper falling off.
Back then you could run a car over and
he'll still steal a little bitty dent and
go on about your way. Yeah.
It's a different also the now car cars
handled good. They have airbags. Yeah.
There's some good, some good shit about
today's cars too, right? Yeah. Try self.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you ever do one
though? You had been in a Tesla.
We just talk about time on a
wheel there. Freakouts man,
it'll freak you out like you driving that
thing. Oh my God. They fast this shit.
It's ridiculous. Right? Did
you ever drive one? Yeah, dude.
The crazy thing about the
Teslas is it's like a race car.
It's like, and you'd be
waiting for it to be like
[inaudible] like, but it don't never
changed gears. It's just straight.
You can all of a sudden it's 150
miles an hour like that. It's so fast.
Disney make sense? It's like a
race car. It's like a time machine.
It's like a compressed time,
like there's a certain amount
of time in a normal car.
You feel like you have to go?
There's a certain amount of time that
has to take place before I can get in
front of that guy and then get over
here and then get to the on ramp with a
Tesla. You just go shoot, you're there.
It's like time like press
zero to 60 in 2.4 seconds.
You never even felt anything like it.
It so God damn roller coaster ride.
It's like you're pinned to your
seat. It's just going like fuck.
And they're making a faster one to go.
One's going to be 1.9 the Roadster.
That really slick looking little
tiny one. They're ridiculous.
That's the future. Yeah, I got
it. Demon. Oh, Dodge demon.
Oh those are nice. It's fun.
That's a fun fucking, who is that?
Like 800 horsepower. Think
909 800 something crazy.
It's crazy. After anything over
seven signed my rights away. Really?
You guys signed all these papers talking
about if you die or get seriously
injured and K nobody else
come back and Sue them.
All kinds of crazy shit. Wow. The car
so fast. They letting you know, like,
you know, you can get real life fucked up.
And does they make those in a stick
shift or is it just an automatic Oh,
I don't know. I got on. I man, it's
a crazy amount of power, but I think,
I think nowadays you got the passengers.
Yeah. Paddle shifters. That's cute.
Where you could put manual shifting with
your left foot in a clutch and shifting
gears. You're right. That's like
part of the whole muscle car thing,
right? Yeah. Part of the old school thing.
You don't want to old school
automatic. It seems silly. You know,
you just think [inaudible]
school. Yeah, that's true.
It's way faster. Oh, it's way faster.
Cars today are way faster period.
And they're all gonna be electric than
10 years. They're just so much better.
They're so much faster. Right.
As long as they can figure out how to
make it charge quick. That's the thing.
The gas, as you just
pull into a gas station,
10 minutes later you got a full tank.
Right? So your cart charges up. Yeah.
I'm going to take,
let's take a good solid six or seven
hours. If it's dead, if it's almost dead,
it'll take like six or seven hours at
a super. I have a supercharger too.
Normally it might take 12 like
with a regular outlet. Yeah.
Fuck it takes a long time. Yeah. Yeah.
So if you pull into like
one of those supercharges,
I think they can get you up to like 80%
in like an hour to the first charge.
The first 80% quit pretty quick. So you
could do that [inaudible] for gas. Yeah.
Yeah. You pay for it. Yeah. You
use a credit card for it. Yeah,
I seen them there. What?
The airport's free.
You could plug in at the airport and it's
free. It's a, it's a weird experience,
man, because I love the
sound of engines. But uh,
that car makes them all look stupid.
They all, they all seem dumb. It does,
right? Yeah. You don't hear
that, but it's on the, yeah,
I gotta have that muscle
muscle. It's fun. Yeah.
I'm wondering, once you get into
the, you can't burn out in it. Nah,
there's no burning out. It's just
Gusto. It makes a noise like this wish,
like it doesn't make any noise.
It doesn't like [inaudible] there's
none of that just takes off.
Yeah. It doesn't even
seem real. I like them.
The inside is crazy with the
big screen touch and, yeah, no,
they're pretty dope. You just look
like you're in a future where state,
it feels like you're in the futuristic.
What, what do you spend your money on?
Do you have a thing that you,
uh, you indulge in? Nah, that's,
I don't really have no spinning
habits. Just, that's the main stuff.
Fishing and, yeah,
we were talking before the show about
bonefish and you're like, bonefish.
I love it. I love it.
I got took on both fishing
one time and I've been hooked.
I've been spending money on it.
We actually walked in his pond.
I bought waiters, I got
waiters and everything.
So I'm out there in a water
in a little mud and stuff,
hitting the little guards and, and uh,
anything I can find. Do you, uh, do you
eat guards? You smoked those, right?
You can't eat them? No, no, no. We,
we mainly trying to get the grass carp
cause they, they're invasive. Right.
They tried to kill as many of
those as they can. Right. Yeah.
So it's crazy though
because the Asian carp,
we own my boat,
we in the river and this was the other
night we going through this little spot
in the river and they started jumping
in the boat. Yeah. That's not weird.
Have you ever seen him? Yeah, I've seen
all of these TV shows. Fucking crazy.
They like this big, no lie. They
was like, you say car jumping park,
no Asian cart, seven pounds.
And they'd fly through the air and hit
you in the face different than grass
card. We will shoot in grass carpet
and uh, and a pine. But in the river,
the Asian carp dye was jumping in
my boat was every bit of 30 pounds
and they're hitting people in the head,
hay on them, flat line them. I said,
didn't they bring those States,
those carbons over to eat
up something in a something?
Look at these things here.
These people fly a boat and got
hit in the back of the head. Right?
That side ain't joke. Both.
What are these guys are trying to
shoot them while they're flying?
That is so ridiculous.
What are the rednecks
rednecks court Saturday?
What kind of fucking fish just flows
itself out of boat? It's so crazy.
The sound of the engine that you get
them started. Something like that.
It's crazy. Like this'll
give you a target panic man.
You're not going to get good at shooting
a bow and arrow and getting hit in the
head while you're pulling back your bow.
Or these guys are just trying to shoot.
No one's even pulling the trigger. Oh
man. That's funny. Look at that. Pop.
Yeah. Look, these keeps getting
hit donk. What a weird dude.
I just got clipped laughing going.
Gasbag Eddy duck. The second one.
I'll get it. Oh. Oh, that
guy got nailed. Yeah,
I'd have a bat finishing
with a base on a B boat.
I'm telling you what a samurai
sword mugs get big [inaudible] part.
What was that in the river river.
So they're trying to kill
as many of those they can.
They're trying to kill as
many of those as they can.
Those things have overpopulated
lakes just taken over.
I don't know why they brought him
in though originally and more.
More so of the lakes is grass cart,
not Asian carp and some rivers
big red looking ones here.
Those get huge like yeah
you have [inaudible] it's
crazy enough alone in America
we think of them as shit.
There's like trash fish but
in England they're prized.
Like in England they have carp fishing
contests and they have certain carbs that
they catch and they weigh in and then
they release them and then they catch them
again like a year later.
Like they know the carp and like they
were in world records like the wholly
caught mr fishy again or
mr fishy is now, you know,
85 fucking pounds and they keep catching
them year after year until these things
die and when they die
they make like a big deal.
We lost his car but they take
carp fishing super serious.
Which is so strange because over here
in America we think of them as trash.
They eat everything. Yeah. When,
when we see the Asians fishing
and whatever they catch they,
they keep, yeah, so it's like the Gar,
the Asian carp, they eat them up.
Apparently Gar taste good if you
smoke it. That's what I've heard.
I've heard he gets smoked car.
Not fucking one that to dinosaur.
I feel w it's a weird thing to eat.
It's like eating a snag. I shot him.
I didn't shop one just to look at the
meat and it's all hard hot like autumn
pones how are you going clean that
day? Yeah, I saw a guy do it on TV.
Can I cooked it on TV? I forgot. What
was one of those wild game cooking shows?
He smoked a Gar.
I could see an alligator guard like
when you go down like the Texas or so,
is that a different kind of guard?
Alligator guard and the mugs get pig.
Maybe that's what it is, you know,
but the guard that we got a little skinny
little pencil wool things like, Oh,
so they're tiny. Yeah. They
like that big eight long. Yeah.
Those Texas ones are freakish, man. They
don't even look real. But listen, man,
I'm not gonna take up
any more of your time.
I just want to tell you I'm a big fan.
It was an honor having you in here.
I really appreciate watching you fight.
One of my favorite, I think when I,
when I talk to people about, about
combat sports,
one of the things that I always talk
about is like the difference between the
skill level of an elite boxer.
When you see what that's all
they do versus like an MMA,
you see openings and MMA that you would
never see like in boxing. So I'm just,
I'm happy you're out there,
man. I appreciate it. And I,
and let us know when your fight is.
We'll let everybody know and, um,
just alert the world. I'm excited.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, man. Thanks.
Bye everybody.
I'll make them get a picture. Yeah.
[inaudible].